welcome ladies and gentlemen to
um this um meeting of community
resources
i'm anna dark the vice chair and um
[Music]
is that better
[Music]
is that better
substituting councillor hodgson
councillor harley's substitution
and councillor mcgowan thank you
and we need to agree the minutes of the
community and resources
committee meeting held on the 26th of
april
i'll take them page by page
so page one
[Music]
page two
page three
and page four oh page three yeah okay
that's unlocked
page four on the patterns of rising is
that captain rock referred to the weekly
planning list
i think that should read the weekly plan
thank you okay so all in favor of
approving those minutes apart from that
amendment
i proposed
all in favor
and against
and abstentions
lovely
okay do we have any public contributions
and we now need to look at the forward
plan
so on the forward plan
there are a list
of items which need to be brought
forward but not necessarily
for our next meeting and so i think
we're going to take it that we
reallocate
at an appropriate month suitable for the
timeline it's going to take to do with
work so
are we all happy with that
yeah yeah
secondary
counselor laws all in favor
[Music]
and then we need to agree the agenda
between
our owner declarations of interest
[Music]
we missed the action list can we have an
update on the action
i think just some confusion about uh the
actual
item on there and i think we can assume
that's
dealt with we were gonna get a report
from adrian
but i don't think we've done it have we
we haven't been able we haven't been
able to get over the
appropriate officer this afternoon so
we'll make sure that's circulated to
members of the committee okay are you
happy with that counselor
okay agreements of agendas between part
one and two can i have a proposal
can i have a secondary counselor thank
you all in favor
and then urgent matters of information
to be brought forward with permission of
the chair of the committee i think
james would like something yeah could i
just update you coach
uh hicks is not sharing tonight he's had
operation
um i think it must be the name of last
week sorry i've lost track of days
um but he i spoke to him lunchtime and
he's feeling fine
um he's available for phone and zoom
meetings
and we'll shortly be resuming his place
here but he can't
until he well he needs a driver to bring
him here
so um that's something we're looking at
so as soon as he can he will be
coming back to meet us thank you thank
you
and we wish him a speedy road to
recovery
and the next item is a road to recovery
chris willa would you like to take over
thank you very much
it's my first time in accessing some uh
technologies if uh
microphone use is inaccurate and
hopefully the report very much speaks
for itself along with the prospectus
document itself
i think this all stemmed from
almost a logical chain that
last summer the heart of the southwest
published there building black better
prospectus
then leading down to the team devon
coded
19 economy and business recovery
prospectus
and then making sure that actually we
were selling
ourselves and attracting both attention
investment and also being quite open
about our intentions
for the northern devon economy
moving forward we wanted to make sure
that
actually we were pitching this in a very
upbeat
positive way to ensure that
we weren't really selling it as not just
a recovery
but actually making sure that we do come
out of this
crisis in a far far stronger position
and i hope that that comes
through in the recovery prospectus and
as it mentions the recovery prospectus
will be a corresponding
action plan where
i think part of the day has been the
fact that we
in terms of the torah's side want that
action plan to be
very ambitious and to be very um
open to then gather further attention
and hopefully draw other participants in
so that it's not just a local authority
sort of delivering on this by itself but
it is a wider
piece um this will then ultimately
lead through into being less of a
short-term document
and then moving towards a replacement
for the economic strategy that ran out
in
2020 but it didn't feel appropriate to
develop a new economic strategy
in the middle pandemic with all the
uncertainty when actually
what we do at the moment is a short-term
um recovery don't even probably need to
go into
any more detail than that but obviously
and if there are any questions
[Music]
any questions counselor christine yeah
um
fascinating thank you chris um can i
just ask one thing that
slightly worries me the um on page 20
you've got the covered 19
impact and
one of the major impacts that i think
we're all aware of and actually
almost spiraling out of control is uh
house prices locally
um it is i keep hearing i'm sure we've
all heard
anecdotal evidence about you know houses
going on the market and selling within
two hours i've talked to local surveyors
who said that they are standing houses
off the net without people even seeing
them and they say yeah we'll buy it
and that is going to be an enormous
impact in torridge
because if you look at page 21 of your
paper it says giving young people a fair
chance
i'm not sure how we can do it but we
certainly do need to do it
and the last bullet point on page 21
supporting high quality housing
employment land delivery
i think we need to really contact
our mp and say look what is happening
now it may be the time to do it after
you know the government just lost the
by-election apparently on the planning
system and i think we need to contact
them and say look we are
in dire strength down here because
suddenly because of covered
we've become incredibly attractive and
with the wonderful roll out of fibre
down here people can work from home and
yeah
the imp it looks good but you've got
money coming in and all this sort of
thing
but the impact on our young people is
enormous
um and we do need to really build that
into any
future plans i think
thank you anyone else
councillor leather thank you gerald i'm
not a member of this commitment
i'll just draw members attention to page
six
of northern devon
[Music]
[Music]
it seems to be admitted far too often
documents that we
get before us so i'm not very happy
about that perhaps somebody will get
that lecture thank you
thank you yeah councillor christine oh
it's actually worse than that because
there's my map the whole
foreign
are we happy is there any old counseling
yeah
i was really surprised
yeah counselor yes i i support
chancellor christie uh it's awful now
um being in a business and speaking to
the customers a lot of them are young
they're just giving up hope of ever
being able to own their own home
and it's really i know there's little we
can do
but how sad that is
and how we're going to lose our talent
they're going to have to
they're gonna have to move away and
that's really sad because in many ways
we're just beginning to really flourish
but it has a
severe downside we must contact our
and make our position clean
thank you thank you
thank you to be fair i mean it's always
been difficult for young people no
matter where they
and we've said ever since i've been on
this council i've heard
and i agree it's very very difficult for
young people to go on the ladder even
down here
so things have become more difficult but
still in the same position
as were several years ago as pricing
have
got across the country i don't think the
government can do supply and demand has
said that house prices will grow and i
do agree
people can't want to come down here
because of the lifestyle because of
being shut away in houses in
states etc further up but there's very
little we can do
as a council um to make houses more
affordable for young people
and that means bringing prices down
dramatically really dramatically
thank you councillor james
i just suggest that we've got um coming
up next week i think
meetings to discuss um future hosing
policy
and how we're going to try and tackle
some of these issues we are also on the
local plan
looking how we can enforce more
affordable hosing within the planning
structure
um so i think we need to be proactive
we're not going to change the market
what we have to do is find ways of
providing what our local people need
and as you know i do that through a
housing trust but i think we can expand
that within the council
to look at what we do many councils are
already doing their own hoses
we've got issues there because we
haven't got
an hra or whatever and anyway um so
we've got difficulties with doing that
but let's just say
difficult to see usually there to be
overcome so as many people as possible
if they can attend the hosting meetings
um and we start to develop a policy that
we put to the local planning committee
or the working group
of how we can ensure that we do deliver
the hoses we're not going to change the
market we're not going to stop second
homes
but what we can do and we should be
doing is using our own
planning policy to deliver what we need
um so thank you thanks joe
i am absolutely concerned with all those
comments and
actually it's really close to my heart
because my
son is growing up rapidly and it's going
to affect him very soon so
i think young people face a challenge
and it's something
that whilst you can be as passionate as
you like actually changing
things and making a difference is very
different even on the local plan working
with the frustration is
immense um so
we must continue to do all we can
counselor christine
i'd like us to follow up the idea of
contacting the mp
if only to try and get some movement
in the delivery of housing because we've
we're granting planning permissions for
very large estates and nothing's getting
built
because the companies land banking their
way you know prices are going up why
should they
build out um this is one of the problems
that we've got all these uh permissions
that aren't being actually put into
practice
and i wonder if the mp could actually
bring that to the attention of the prime
minister
yeah i have to say this is being raised
in the local plan working group because
whilst you know government won't build
out the council
won't build out the cancer actually held
to account over the amount of build out
that we get
and actually the control just isn't
there
so there is huge frustration so whether
we can take that any further
whether we need a proposal yeah
would someone like to propose that
councillor christie
councillor jones seconding yes no
go on wait break it right oh brian come
on
it's because i haven't been out for a
long time
yeah cancer bright are you going second
nothing
okay all in favor
thank i ask you a question yes
uh on page 19 i don't know what says the
need for leveling up
and just query some of the figures
because at the top
top of that page it says storage is the
third lowest
workplace earning for full-time work
with the uk that is 370 districts
the 440 pounds monthly it surely counted
right
not monthly 110
a week no 1100
i don't think they're accurate
yeah can i make a point about building
um
some of the sites are being bought
at a high price and
there is about an eighteen percent
margin left for
profit and planning mission being given
building materials have risen alarmingly
in the last year so that prevents some
of the building
out taking place and again
escalates the price of housing now
i look around the committee tonight
and a lot of the makeup of this
committee
is shall we say biddeford and north and
i appreciate
half the population of torridge is north
a bit of the town hall
but we have a very large rule
hinterland that is earning
very very little money now at the end of
the day
torridge was one of the 10 worst
districts
in this country affected by coronavirus
north devon has that ribbon of tourism
the hinterland has a very sparse
economic position and i know it's not
relevant to us but i was on a committee
at the back end of last year when i
heard that
90 percent of the income the dartmoor
hill farmers came from subsidies
now i would suggest the farming
communities
in torridge to the southern end
in particular would have that deficit of
income
and they face a very very uncertain
future
and i think we've got to realize that
thank you thank you
right oh counselor laws yeah
i'm sorry i'm not intending to be a film
star or anything
um surely
one of the problems is that they apply
for planning permission
the developers and they're gambling on
prices going up and they just move this
lump of land around
surely if the planning system
will be a government legislation if the
period was shortened
from four years before your planning
commission ran out if that was shortened
down to two years
it would concentrate their minds before
spending a lot of money
on designs and getting planning
[Music]
deck in case the bush beat all in favour
[Music]
brilliant
[Music]
i should just now interject and say if i
miss
declarations of interest you obviously
all know
that you need to declare an interest if
appropriate
so we have the
yes i'm sorry i meant to ask you the
second
recommendations there steve hurts
explain what that's about why is it
stuck in there it looks really odd
[Music]
so it's linked to kind of the welcome
back
fund and bringing back our
communities our towns and
the government's incentive to
allow markets to operate
and to promote markets operating
so we've had discussions i think
suggestions from northern about having
a possibility of market in westwood hall
but similar conversations
at battle door and there's a current
uh decision in place that restricts
any markets taking place within six
miles of biddyhood
planning money market without a
subsequent
cnr report and decision
um so it's that recommendation is about
setting that aside for a short period
whilst the economy
is recovering to allow markets to
operate
um for the period up until the end of
december 22.
well thank you but i should point out
this i can remember 30 years ago when
this came up and there was a
open air market down the sports ground
in biddeford and uh
i think reference was made to the
elizabethan charter of biddeford which
forbids it
i'm not sure if you've been overruling
quite as easy there i've got no problem
with it but
uh i just mentioned that in particular
well councillor christie we've now
recommended that we do overrule it so
let's hope we can
okay thank you chris david you're on
i'm telling you let's move on to the
next line please
just by way of background it's the local
photo pension's been changed in 2014
and it's called care which is career
ambiguities prior to that
and the pension was based on a final
salary
which was obviously a great benefit to
somebody who got a pay award and towards
the end of their working career now it's
not quite so generous to the employees
um as a consequence of that we had to
adopt a
discretionary pension policy which we
did in 2014
and we're obligated by the devon
financial pension service
to have a discretionary pension policy
but we've not amended that policy since
2014 we've actually been contacted um
this year by different potential
pensions and actually
they've advised that we really need to
clarify some elements of it regarding
flexible retirement and that's what the
paper
circulated as well but i thought it
might be just an opportune moment for
members to actually
be aware of what's in our pensions
discretionary policy because it is
since 2014 is the last time it ever came
before the community
and resources committed not the next
flight please tom
so the first one the power of him
playing the foreign additional pension
we as an employer can choose to grant
extra pension
at full cost to ourselves sorry district
council to an active member
are to remember we've been six months of
leaving the employment of the authority
our policy says we don't um take up that
option because it'll be a cost to the
council
shared costs additional pension
contributions
so there is a active members can wish to
purchase additional years of service by
making additional voluntary pension
contributions apc
and an employer can choose to
voluntarily contribute to the cost of
purchasing
the extra pension through a shared cost
additional pension contribution
and the council has chosen uh not to
adopt that positive that
slight caveat to that is where
somebody's taken
a period of approved unpaid leave
and when they come back they can say i
want my pension made up for that period
of time
and the council has to come through
two-thirds of the cost of that
i'm just so just you know obviously um
[Music]
for every one pound an employee puts
into the pension scheme
the council puts in about two and a half
pounds
two pound fifty so obviously we try to
make up and buy some of those years of
services but have any expense option for
the employee it's also very expensive
for the council
we could have the next slide
um switch on the 85-year rule what a
shame for people like me this isn't
still in place
essentially that is the if you add in
your years of service in your age you
can pick up your full pension that used
to be the rule
we had the option in the policy to
actually turn that on
but the council decided in 2014 not to
do that
mainly because it was very very
expensive because we
built those costs um and we can
waive the actual reduction to members
benefits when an employee decides to
leave early
we can wait and they'll they'll have
their pension reduced because if you
post a word to the
agreed pension if you leave early 55 657
your pension is reduced
and we can as a council if we wanted to
waive that reduction and that would be
our cost to this council so the policies
that we don't uh
do that so we can just move on
so this is the error really which is the
purpose of the report which is really
looking at the flexible
retirement so um
i could inferior tomorrow ask you could
i go down to three days a week
um get three fifths of my salary to pick
up my reduced pension because i'm
leaving early
and actually maybe on the same money
maybe perhaps even beyond slightly more
money that's what's flexible retirement
is people can reduce their hours
whilst picking up the pensions slowly
disappearing to the sunset so to speak
um but we needed to clarify some points
in our policies the first one we did
was um if we considered a request for
flexible retirement
it's based on the needs of the service
does it work so steve in that instance
might say no i don't i don't want a
section one pad one of us who's on part
time i need a section one that one
time the minimum reduction in hours that
we would consider would be one day a
week
and we'd have no issue about any
reduction in grades that's not
irrelevant
but we would inquire and plan would
require an employee to commit to
remaining employment in the council for
at least one year
we went down the flexible retirement
route
and the bottom one there tories will
allow members to take all
parts while none of their benefits are
crippling first of april 2008 and first
first march 2014
and to take all part or none of the
benefits of crew
after two fifties about 2014. so to
translate that waffle
that's basically saying you can take all
the pension that you've accrued
we wouldn't limit it in any way so you
can take your maximum pension you can
get
we would allow you to do that and if you
do that
it may make uh flexible retirement more
attractive to people
because they would suffer less of a drop
in income taking the full
pension they can admittedly reduced
because they take they've gone early
um and we won't wave on compassionate
ground the actual reduction
applied to benefits members benefits
paid on grounds and flexible returns so
if you take flexible retirement
at 55 56 and your pensions reduced by 35
40
the council won't be uh making good that
difference that's that's your decision
so i think there's a recommendation in
the report which is simply
to make amendments to the pension
discretion policy to clarify
what we would consider in terms of
flexible retirement
happy to take any questions and address
them to answer
any questions thank you david
thanks a lot
it says with regards to flexible
retirement requests the capital reserves
the right to refuse when it is not
satisfied
who actually makes the decision to
refuse
that would be in my case they say with a
member of my team
i suppose in myself in control
consultation with hr would make that
decision if it's operationally efficient
to do that
so um so for example i've got somebody
who works four days a week because you
want to
reduce to one day a week it might make
it better actually works um
certain hours let's say lunchtime i may
think
actually it's going to be difficult to
recruit somebody to fill those over
hours it just makes it operationally
difficult
you probably for example the best better
example that would be a bin
you couldn't really do a bin then he's
only going to work till lunchtime
because you get you know he just gets
off the vehicle and buggers off at
lunchtime it doesn't really
help in the operation of a crew going
out and picking up bins
so there'd be factors like that i think
the council would always be positively
minded to in an office environment it's
more likely
we could accommodate people but it's
things like an abandonment or a loader
or a street cleanse would be more
difficult to do not a very good example
because they're all going by dinner time
anyway
we're still going right now i think
we've worked very hard to learn
[Music]
we'll get up here baby
counselor james if there's no more
questions i see i'm going his new member
view
and i recommend the acceptance of this
amended policy
i think i understand it i rely on
if an employee decides to maybe cut down
to four days a week
and like you said they may well they'll
make their money out by taking
money from their pension pot they decide
to retire
five years later how does that impact on
the amount they would get at that
five year point well i've taken the
pension and of course in those five
years if they
wanted to they've added in again so
there will be an adjustment to take
account
that they've paid in in that intervene
in five years
so it's not far too it's at least not
for me to calculate that with the
dividend potential of pensions or
those calculations so really it's
worthwhile doing that
because you're down four days a week
you're probably going to be no worse off
four years later or five years later
when you retire it's an individual's
decision for an employee
yes thank you thank you
else okay i'll go back to the proposal
that's the jane's proposing can we have
a second left
i'll second yeah okay councillor harley
all in favor
you know miss joe thank you sandra
okay and then we need an urgent decision
on the welcome back fund
decisions are taken and we are required
to
report them to the next community
resources committee so this uh
particular urgent
decision was taken in respect to the
welcome back fund that we received from
uh government and the decision was to
allocate a hundred thousand pounds of
that fund
uh to the four main towns
as indicated on page 31
of the report uh so that's been done to
enable
those top councils to make appropriate
plans
and start discussions around what
activities they'd like to pursue to
welcome
back is largely meant for weaponry back
visitors
so those monies have been distributed
and hamish is working with all the town
councils
uh to pull together the plans because
they need to be submitted to
mhclg or approval
so that's the decision that's taken
chair
is only for no two
okay are we all does anyone have any
questions
comments are we happy to note the report
right and then um we need to vote
on the fact that we need to go into part
two
so we need
so